so as another big hurricane heads our
way let's not forget Harvey and what it
showed us after all that havoc we saw a
category 6 downpour of compassionate
action anyone still bickering over
politics appeared petty no different
than the guy complaining that his steak
is overcooked to a starving child the
extremists who before could easily find
a spotlight are left shouting at the
bedroom mirror so what's left
cooperation let's take this debt deal I
know how dare Donald Trump make a deal
with evil Nancy Pelosi conservatives
they're really ticked but this is
clearly related to the Hurricanes what's
he supposed to do and should you be
surprised he was a deal maker before he
was a Republican we knew that it's one
reason he won Trump does what suits him
or what suits America and that's the
point you can disagree with him on small
stuff but if you think that he gets the
big picture than so what that America
first stuff what if he means it then
party line deviations are forgivable
after all all he did was put America
first or in this very case an American
crisis first figuring that the food
fights can happen three months from now
and they will the media is shocked but
you're not Trump may know what America
is looking for right now and it's not a
fight not when you're reeling from two
hurricanes you want help not haggling
the tips can come later when everyone is
safe and dry and so as we unite to face
these threats I feel for the critics but
it's Rachel Maddow said to Chris
Matthews darling we'll always have
Russia right Dana I think Donald Trump
acted in good faith to keep the
government going while dealing with
these disasters but the conservatives if
you go on Twitter they're ticked off
they feel that they've been they were
proven correct that he's not really a
conservative do they have a reason to be
upset well I think in some ways yes
partly because President Trump had all
the leverage going into the meeting in
order to get the debt ceiling passed for
18 months so that he could clear the
decks and do all the other things that
he wants to do one of the reasons you
have debt ceilings
is um well actually I actually think
that you don't necessarily need them
anymore because it always gets raised
and they're supposed to be used in order
to cut spending that's what the
Republicans actually wanted to do that
wasn't going to happen when you have the
hurricane release happening at the same
time so I I could see the frustration
though because it was the Treasury
secretary that wanted the 18 months and
president trunk didn't make a deal he
just took the first offer that was made
and so three months from now we'll be
sitting back here the reason I think
that there's also frustration is that if
you go in with a plan because you have
all the leverage against your opponent
and you give that away if the most
important thing is tax reform and you
want that done before December you
actually now have to have another debt
ceiling fight in December and it muddies
the waters it makes things difficult
speaking of muddy waters Jessie geez um
don't you think though that if you got
bogged down in this sort of thing it
would look bad and it may have been bad
because you're dealing with some serious
devastation and maybe saying like I'll
deal with this now you can have this and
later I trust you in good faith that we
will work together that's my theory I
agree I think Trump got trapped this
summer and Harvey gave him a little bit
of an escape hatch he wasn't able to
govern with Republican majorities they
failed him especially with Obamacare so
now he hits bottom at Charlottesville
but then he got a little lifeline with
Harvey because he recognized the spirit
of unity that came out of Texas and he
seized on it and he capitalized on it
and he is a deal maker you say the
president's like the weather where he's
always swirling and he's always around
he's not an ideologue so he goes into
this debt ceiling battle and both sides
are on this side both sides are on that
side they're dug in and he says you know
what listen we're not going to do this
he reaches across the aisle shakes hands
with the Democrats and that's a signal
to the Republicans and say you know what
you guys better unite and get your act
together because I'm in a wheel and deal
and triangulate anyway the Republicans
always lose on debt ceiling fights they
always cave he just did it early and is
now going to take the hit so he gets rid
of Harvey he gets that money out there
he funds the military and he's the
government keeps spending it at the same
time the next three months you can go
out and sell tax reform what do this
does though it does set up this huge
intense showdown in December where you
have daca
you have the wall funding you even have
a bomb acara fix you have tax reform so
that's going to be a huge feat can I be
honest be honest if McConnell and Ryan
had come into the meeting and said you
know what we think we should take the
deal that the first offer that Pelosi
and Schumer are offering then what would
what would the Trump supporters have
said they would have said oh they're the
weak ones I mean that's why I think the
debates actually very frustrating
because you can defend this on either
side but let's just be honest about it
if they had done this you guys would
have gone crazy again I think he was
looking for a moment to say hey you know
what we're going to be bipartisan come
together this is a new government cut
why you get that - his friend Harry in
the meeting this is well the Treasury
secretary now says we can now sell
checks everybody's on every month
everybody's on board and I don't know if
the country didn't want a stomach
fretting all over a debt ceiling what
we're doing the hackers or emma-crats or
joint above it here's the thing - so
Republicans have gotten concessions
before with the debt ceiling we did it
with a Budget Control Act against
President Obama is working in Congress
at the time where we did get concessions
offer the sequestration so that's and
the problem is that Democrats are going
to do that in a couple in three months
from now on issues like immigration and
tax reform things like it you look I do
have money for Harvey coming in and you
have North Korea right now I think that
this truck ssin it on the governor I
think this was a shot across the bow to
Mitch Mitch McConnell and Paul Ryan
because I think President Trump is very
frustrated at their failure to get
things like health care reform done but
means but this to be fair this was not a
deal right like we talked about the art
of the deal this was not the art of the
deal this is art of the giveaway he gave
Democrats every single thing that they
wanted to add insult to injury he went
out to North Dakota State the he won by
36 points brought Heidi Heitkamp one of
the most vulnerable Democrats in the
entire country on stage and said she was
a good woman Proctor up I work on
campaigns you have to believe that her
people her reelection campaign were
sitting there saying or you just through
with a lifeline this is the golden
ticket they're going to use this in
campaign ads and at and also she's gonna
vote heart attacks against and then
we're gonna lose republic in the next
election so I think he accomplishes both
goals look I think that I think
bipartisanship we
need more of it I don't blame him for
wanting to reach across the aisle I
think there's room for that with tax
reform and I want to say I think that's
repeat reason people elected him they
wanted him to get things done they
wanted something different that being
said this was not a deal he could have
done better this was a giveaway and even
given them circumstances he could have
got more from them and he didn't alright
you want I want to add this other piece
to this Donald Trump tweeted
reassurances about daca at the behest of
Nancy Pelosi did you see that other
territory so this should make you happy
right it's like he's like Natan at him
and Nancy and he's Nancy saying hey you
got to tell everybody that nothing
nothing's gonna happen and he did it
that's got it she got him to go on the
record yeah but you know what strikes me
and all this is I'm sitting here I'm
listening to you guys and I think boy
you're just loving that the Republicans
and how you know you got a Republican
majority in the house or a Republican
Megara Senate you got a Republican
president and they've been unable to
govern and so now you see the faction
splitting and in fact Trump except
except you a ting accentuating the
differences and I think you know I mean
he had dinner with Paul Ryan tonight but
the fact is he threw Paul Ryan under the
bus big time cuz Ryan had said this was
an unacceptable deal he said it
explicitly and you have Mitch McConnell
up there who's trying to push the
situation so that you can get tax reform
done that's what Steve manukan was
talking about manukan wants a tax reform
deal
ideally more than just the tax cut Trump
apparently was more interested in
avoiding the idea of a jam-packed
potentially explosive September and
giving himself time but now we do so in
such a way that he would actually
resolve the problem in fact as you were
saying it now becomes more of an
explosive situation in December and
Democrats wholly advantage well any of
the things with like the wall trying to
get funding for the wall you he loses
leverage in that debate because
Democrats could tie the debt ceiling
vote to immigration and Blake blanket
amnesty and not getting things like the
wall done I think these are all
important issues if there were no
hurricanes if there were no hurricanes
I'd go you're absolutely right yeah but
we have two hurricanes and I think he
said on good faith you know what we got
three months I'll give you I'll see you
in three months it's gonna be bad three
months but right now let's focus on
what's happened so it looks so great so
negative voted
because I'm looking into this other
world here you're not I'm saying to
myself so you mean Trump supporters will
back him no matter what he does even if
he sticks his finger in their eyes I
don't think Trump supporters have a lot
of sympathy for Mitch McConnell and Paul
Ryan oh I don't think what a lot of the
quraan that's right no wait a man or to
be frustrated at Paul Ryan I'm calling
it second these are Republican leaders
their elected official they haven't lead
we would have had Obamacare repeal I
want it was fun to watch question cuz
it's a good one how can they deal with
this number one I go back to the big
picture the big thing Trump did a few
big things number one he beat Hillary
that's number one number two we got
Gorsuch number three he killed the Paris
Accords number forty flat Dyson's he
reduced regulations he responded swiftly
to disaster you get to this point it's
like I kind of think he gets me I'm okay
with this yeah but you look at the
numbers and look at the numbers among
Republicans I see them declining even
among his core supporters there and I
don't think I don't think I think they
feel like he has disappointed them and
unity of course you have all the
constant tweeting and controversies that
I don't think help to unify the
Republican brain and will talk to you
about the Republican Party you stick
with the Democrats yeah yeah you're
you're you're you're in crisis that's
what you uh you're getting wet
I think right all I know is I really
enjoyed watching CNN have to admit what
a great job Trump did talking about
there Oh awkward his newsroom meeting
Wow he did a really good job a white
let's talk about Russia now there is a
math writer now I was watching CNN after
that put that presser where he brought
up the and like they sat there like I
can't beat that and can talk about how
great of a statesman the president is
for agreeing with Nancy Pelosi and Chuck
said isn't that what you guys want oh
yes where was all that well Chuck and
Nancy show but I just can't believe that
Republicans are sitting here saying oh
he did a great job just wonderful Wow if
I said that you guys would be down my
throat that is no it's not